nous disons que nous allions arrêter, ils voulaient
voir les ruines que vous Louis - sur le chemin du
retour à l'aéroport quand vous l'attrapez,
vous savez que nous le
ferons probablement et comment vous êtes-vous
rencontrés, nous nous sommes rencontrés il y a environ 18 ans, nous en quelque
sorte  sommes tombés amoureux et une décennie
plus tard nous nous sommes rencontrés non non non
tu as écrit un livre et j'ai lu à ce sujet et je suis
allé chercher oh c'est très romantique
si nous nous rencontrons pour la première fois
aujourd'hui dans un train est-ce que tu t'arrêterais
en me parlant, me demanderiez-vous de descendre du
train avec vous,
bien sûr, cet endroit est tellement rempli de
milliers d'années de tragédie de la méthode et j'ai
quelque chose de tragique qui allait arriver,
allons-y, ils sont toujours là, pas
tous oh ouais rien  Je vais arrêter de
reluquer les filles moi je n'aime pas les
filles Armel je leur fais l'amour oh
je suis coincé avec un adolescent américain je
me sens proche de toi ouais mais parfois je
ne sais pas j'ai envie de respirer de l'hélium
et je respire  oxygène qu'est-ce qui te fait
dire que
je voulais que tu dises quelque chose de romantique
dans ton ok toi  es maire de Crazytown
sais-tu que tu
es c'est comme ça que les gens commencent à se séparer oh
mon dieu
je t'assure que ce gars tu te
souviens vaguement du doux romantique quand tu t'es rencontré
dans un train c'est moi
pourquoi je me retrouve ouais
[Musique]